donde nos quedamos en el último vídeo
llegamos a una expresión como función de
x basados en el punto donde hicimos el
corte sobre el segmento y ahora
necesitamos ver cuál es su valor mínimo
y para hacerlo necesitamos calcular su
derivada ver donde no está definida o si
es cero en algún punto y sólo faltaría
asegurarnos de que ese es un valor
mínimo así que déjenme reescribir un
poco esto porque el área combinada el el
área combinada en términos de x pues por
un lado es si desarrollamos esto es raíz
de 3 x x cuadrada sobre 4 x 3 al
cuadrado que son 99 4 por 9 son 36 y
ahora sumamos la otra parte que es 100
menos x al cuadrado sin menos x al
cuadrado sobre 4 al cuadrado que son 16
16 muy bien entonces ya con esta
expresión podemos calcular más
fácilmente la derivada quien es la
derivada de la función del área
combinada en términos de x
simplemente es derivar x cuadrada que es
dos veces la raíz de tres perdón es 2x
por esto y entonces nos queda raíz de 3
por equis y como dice perdón
multiplicamos por 2 y aquí dividimos
entre 36 nos queda aquí 18 más ahora
aquí podemos usar la regla de la cadena
porque tenemos algo al cuadrado y eso es
dos veces
100 - x
por bueno y aquí como va un 2 y
dividimos entre 16 nos queda aquí sobre
8 y hay que multiplicar por la derivada
de esto de adentro verdades usando la
regla de la cadena que es menos
ok y ahora esta es la derivada de hecho
bueno podríamos podríamos hacer un
poquito más de álgebra y tenemos raíz de
3 por equis sobre 18 más más aquí
aquí tenemos menos 1 por menos x es más
un octavo de equis y luego también
tenemos menos 1% son menos 100 sobre 8
que esos son menos 12.5 verdad y
entonces ahora si queremos encontrar un
punto x tal que al evaluar esta
expresión en ese punto de x nos dé 0 muy
bien y esto es realmente sencillo por
ejemplo si sumamos de ambos lados 12.5
tenemos 12.5 es igual a la raíz de 3 por
equis o déjenme incluso hacer esto
porque aquí ya tenemos puras cosas que
dependen de x verdad entonces podemos
factorizar y tenemos raíz de 3 sobre 18
más 1 octavo
todos estos multiplican o este para
multiplicar a x entonces de aquí
despejar x es muy sencillo porque
simplemente pasamos esto dividiendo
entonces tendremos que x es igual a 12.5
sobre esta expresión que es raíz de 3
sobre 18 más un octavo y ya hemos
llegado al único punto crítico que
podemos tener en este en este problema
lo único que nos falta verificar es que
en efecto sea un mínimo y eso dependerá
de si la función alrededor de este punto
es cóncava hacia arriba o cóncava hacia
abajo muy bien entonces de hecho vamos a
ver bueno esta expresión es la derivada
entonces déjenme copiarla esto es la
derivada del área combinada es igual a
raíz de 3x sobre 18 más un octavo de x
menos 12.5 entonces para ver la
concavidad de esta de esta función
necesitamos calcular la segunda derivada
del área combinada y esto simplemente es
derivar bueno esto es una constante
entonces me queda raíz de 3 sobre 18
verdad la derivada de esto
un octavo que es la derivada de esto y
si nos damos cuenta este numerito de
aquí siempre es más grande que cero
entonces nuestra función es cóncava
hacia arriba cóncava hacia arriba y
cuando digo que la función es cóncava
hacia arriba quiere decir que la función
la función más o menos se ve como de
esta forma verdad entonces si nosotros
tenemos un punto crítico es decir aquel
punto donde la derivada se anula quiere
decir que este de aquí es un mínimo
verdad entonces este punto de aquí como
la segunda derivada es siempre positiva
este punto de aquí es un mínimo ahora
bien esto realmente no nos dice mucho de
cuánto vale verdad es un poquito
intratable esta expresión pero vamos a
tratar de calcularlo usando la
calculadora entonces tenemos 12.5 que
hay que dividirlo entre toda una
expresión que es
la raíz de hecho
expresarlo así que es la raíz cuadrada
de 3
ok creo que ya la ruina va de nuevo 12.5
/ no otra vez 12 12.5 / ahora sirva la
raíz cuadrada de 3
la raíz cuadrada de 3 sobre sobre 18
sobre 18
más
otra vez de verdad porque por el orden
de las operaciones van de nuevo a horas
y 12.5 entre y vamos a dividir entre una
expresión la primera de ellas es la raíz
cuadrada de 3 sobre sobre 18
es nuestra primera expresión y ahora le
sumamos le sumamos otra expresión
qué es 1 sobre 8 verdad y ahora sí
cerramos toda expresión y le damos igual
y nos queda 56.5
más o menos 56.5 entonces esto es 56.5
metros así que si cortamos aquí arriba
en más o menos aquí esto es 50 y 6.5
metros aproximadamente
en ese punto lo que tendremos es que el
área mínima entre ambas figuras se
alcanza